muy buenas tardes para ustedes pues esta
es de nuevo una población que está en
shock porque pues esto vuelve a traer
esos recuerdos muy amargos de 2016 de
ese atentado terrorista sobre el paseo
de los ingleses aquí en niza y la gente
hemos hablado con algunas de estas
personas que dicen estar en shock pero
había una señora que me decía que ella
había cantado con la coral en la
basílica de nuestra señora de aquí de
niza y que ella de alguna manera sentía
en estos últimos días que había uno de
alguna manera como un ambiente un poco
extraño después del atentado terrorista
en el que murió sam y él para ti este
profesor de colegio hace por un par de
semanas se acerca a parís así que ella
decía que creía que había como algo que
se estaba alimentando poco a poco y que
había generado pues que terminaba hoy
por ejemplo pues en esta serie de
atentados finalmente que se han
presentado en el país se además de esto
pues hemos visto varias personas que han
pasado por aquí han venido a tomar fotos
a dejar de estar en un momento digamos
un poco de recogimiento y al mismo
tiempo hemos visto por ejemplo los a
taxistas que se han mostrado bastante
solidarios con
está sucediendo y de hecho han puesto
cintillos a negros sobre sus carros en
señal de duelo
bueno natale a ustedes llegó en tiempo
récord hasta niza que medidas inmediatas
ha visto usted que se tomaron en la zona
del ataque
bueno pues hay muchísima policía
alrededor en realidad como ustedes ven
no podemos acercarnos más a esta pues de
la de la basílica alrededor hay un
dispositivo policial bastante importante
cuando llegamos hace cerca de una hora y
media pues alcanzamos a ver por ejemplo
la policía forense que estaba haciendo
su trabajo aquí ya ellos se han ido pero
la policía ha continuado acordonando la
zona y en realidad ha sido presidente
imposible incluso para los habitantes
que tienen sus apartamentos en esta
calle que ustedes ven a mis espaldas
incluso pasar desde esta mañana había
una señora que decía yo estoy en shock
pero además no puedo entrar a mi casa
porque por ahora pues hay que demostrar
que se vive donde es un lugar de
residencia que es en esta calle se hemos
visto algunas de las personas que
trabajan en las oficinas aledañas que
han comenzado
salir así que se ha visto muchísima
policía hay que saber que niza es una
ciudad en donde no solamente hay
muchísima policía sino es la ciudad de
francia en donde más cámaras de
vigilancia hay en el país
bueno natalidad y ahora quisiera
preguntarle a tratando de no entrar en
el territorio de la especulación cuáles
son los detalles que se conocen a esta
hora del atacante
pues por ahora digamos que de las
fuentes francesas solamente han dicho
que se trataría de un tunecino de 21
años que habría llegado a francia o
había llegado a europa
lampedusa pero han sido más bien los
medios italianos los que han dado un
poco más de información es todo esto por
supuesto en que hay que verificarlo
completamente con las autoridades
italianas pero según explica en este
joven habría llegado que nacido en marzo
de 1999 habría llegado a lampedusa desde
túnez a finales del mes de septiembre y
allí habría estado en un barco pasando
una cuarentena por causa del hobbit y
allí después de esos quince días habría
recibido un permiso que le permitió
entrar a territorio italiano estuvo en
la región de julia en la ciudad de bari
y allí estuvo y hay digamos que se
pierde un poco la pista de este joven
hasta el día de hoy cuando está aquí en
francia así que hace muy poco que está
acá de hecho se sabe que eso sí que la
fiscalía- tunecina va a abrir también
una investigación hace un momento
ustedes destacaba la comunidad es una de
las ciudades que están más resguardadas
en francia y es que esta no es la
primera vez que la ciudad es un objetivo
terrorista recordamos con mucha tristeza
natalia cuando en 2016 un hombre arrolla
con un camión a los asistentes a un
desfile por la fiesta nacional de
francia 84 personas muertas decenas de
heridos y ahora macro nakhon se ha
convocado un consejo de defensa para el
día de mañana se sabe que otras medidas
podría dar a conocer
por ahora pero lo cierto es que ya pues
francia ha elevado a lo máximo está
alerta terrorista lo cual le permite
pues al gobierno por un tiempo limitado
imponer ciertas restricciones pero hay
que también tener en cuenta que
justamente a la medianoche de este
jueves es cuando comienza el nuevo
confinamiento por espacio de un mes de
aquí hasta normalmente el primero de
diciembre así que esto de alguna forma
esta medida podría venir a ayudar a
calmar un poco la situación a poder no
necesitar tampoco desplegar aún más
fuerza policial aunque como ya lo decían
pues dentro de esta fuerza centinela que
es la que se utiliza digamos para
patrullar en todo el país pues hay siete
mil militares que van a estar por todo
el país y resguardando los lugares de
culto y sobre todo los colegios
justamente cuando este lunes pues los
los niños y los estudiantes vuelven a
sus clases porque a pesar de que hay un
confinamiento lo cierto es que el
presidente quiso que los colegios y los
liceos permanezcan abiertos así que
habrá que esperar que otras decisiones
podrían haber tomarse en este consejo de
defensa pero quizás os van a ser más
decisiones de ver lo que está pasando en
las redes sociales y si hay allí dónde
digamos se están preparando de pronto
nuevos atentados o mirar a ver si este
si este atacante día de hoy pues si
tenía algún tipo de lazos o con algún
tipo de líder
digamos islamista radical